my name is danica rome i'm the virginia
state delegate from the 13th district of
the Virginia House of Delegates I was
elected on November 7th 2017 sworn in on
January 10th 2018 becoming the first out
in seated transgender state legislature
in American history I first realized I
was trans roughly about fifth grade or
so and by the time I was in seventh
grade there was no question about it and
at the same time I was too scared to
tell anyone
it wasn't until college where I really
started telling anyone else at the same
time I didn't really come out fully
until my 30th birthday first I was
telling people I was by then I was
telling them I was gay then I was
explaining I was trans and it was just I
felt each step along the way a little
bit easier for people to understand if I
hadn't come out I wouldn't have met my
partner and if I had it up my partner I
want to become a stepmom and so the most
important parts of my life now that's
because they came out by being able to
be vulnerable enough to be visible in
the first place to put myself out in
front of other people it shows them that
yeah I can succeed because of who I am
my experience as a trans woman has
allowed me to have more empathy and
understanding for other people who might
not look like me who might come from
different backgrounds or they might have
you know just had different world
experiences I do know what it's like to
be single out and stigmatized by the
very elected officials who are elected
to serve people like me and to serve our
communities and so that makes sure that
I'm able to take that compassion take
that empathy and show understanding for
other people to say even if I don't know
what your life is like I stand in
solidarity with you I'm proud because
12000 77 people of the 13th district
took a chance let me in 2017 you don't
have to pretend to be another person you
can be you and I hope that every person
who follows the example that we've said
here in the 13th district knows that
they can succeed because of who they are
not just